localizaciones gps mensajes de texto y
testimonios según omer shatz estos
documentos son la prueba de devoluciones
ilegales por parte de grecia el abogado
representa a una mujer franco turca que
dice haber escapado de una sentencia de
prisión por motivos políticos en turquía
acusan a grecia de rechazarla cuando
intentaba volver a francia violando así
sus derechos como persona que huye de la
persecución política y como ciudadana
europea
les rogaba les mostraba sus documentos
de identidad y de viaje pero la
ignoraban porque por su aspecto
probablemente sea musulmana
probablemente con aspecto de refugiada
probablemente no blanca o malley not
white esta no es la primera vez que se
acusa a grecia de devoluciones ilegales
en las que se obliga a solicitantes de
asilo a regresar por la frontera antes
de tener la oportunidad de presentar su
documentación una investigación
realizada por varios medios entre ellos
el periódico británico the guardian
afirmó que grecia fue responsable en
septiembre pasado de la muerte por
ahogamiento de dos hombres
sin embargo el ministro griego de
migración negó que se produzcan
devoluciones
existe la retórica de que grecia está
practicando devoluciones ilegales en la
anterior investigación realizada por los
mismos periodistas la autoridad nacional
de transparencia pidió las pruebas del
escrito para realizar una investigación
independiente pero se negaron a
entregarlas
según la organización internacional para
las migraciones al menos 21 personas han
muerto en la frontera terrestre entre
turquía y grecia desde principios de
este año frente a las 10 muertes
registradas en el mismo período de 2001